RuPaul in the house good morning good
morning hello good morning before you
say anything glad in the makeup room
this morning radon said is he coming as
RuPaul is he just coming as a pretty man
or he does my makeup so I have to say
you came as a pretty man
I thought that was a good line you say
you're still pinching yourself after all
these years after all these successes
why do you think that I mean why would
you be pinching yourself you deserve all
the accolades well I've been very very
fortunate because in show business as
you well know nothing's guaranteed you
know if you get to return to a job want
another day or a day after that you're
doing great because most things you do
actually are not success you have to
throw a bunch of things up on the wall
something stick most things don't right
so you had Ariana Grande for the start
of season 15. I'm Vlad you've done your
homework that was a very very talented
producers who helped me out but yes what
was that I mean talk to me about that
well a season 15 uh is a blast you know
the kids on the show are so talented and
so excited you saw the you saw the promo
there yes they're so exciting and that's
is what keeps the show so fresh is that
every season we we produce what we can
and then we add the girls who have their
own unique stories they're so courageous
they are so they're Heroes to me because
they come from varied backgrounds a lot
of strife and uh here they are looking
great I'm always looking to see what are
they going to wear because a lot of
times I'm like I want that dress that
dress but the thing is the thing that I
think holds the show of course is you
you've got such great lines gentlemen
start your engines May the best woman
win don't be a drag be a queen yeah well
with that that line we've changed that
um we've changed that to uh uh start uh
ladies start your or we it's changed now
to a more uh open it's not gentlemen
sorry your engines May the best Drag
Queen win interesting yes you're keeping
up with the times exactly but but the
thing is what I like that you do on the
show is you always say who is here to
support you because you always bring out
what I think is so important in the
humanity of all of the people who are on
this show and that's what I think is so
important well that's what the show is
really about it's about the tenacity of
the human Spirit you take away all the
drag and all the colors and all that
stuff and what it boils down to and why
people around the world are so uh
enthralled with this show is the
humanity and the human spirit because
everybody has a dream everybody has had
an uh something they've wanted to do
that's their their passion but not a lot
of people have the courage to do it and
I think watching these kids on our show
do that the courage or the encouragement
to do it both all of it all of it you
need it yeah when you say around the
world you're not kidding the show's
being developed in India Singapore Japan
how do you choose where to go with it
and is there anywhere on the planet
where you think maybe not uh kiddo
there's a very simple answer to that
whoever's willing to pay for the license
you can have it brainer
[Laughter]
and now you've got a new show about that
it's on CBS you're I'm part of this
I'm on lingo which starts January 11th
here on CBS it's a game show it's a a
word game show like I think you like
game shows we run a game show we were on
a game show today I love it it is my
passion you know it's the spice of life
is the playfulness of life and that's
what keeps me getting up every morning
are you focusing on this focus on lingo
I think I'm trying to solve the puzzle I
need help can we be on the show together
I would I would love for you to come and
be on on lingo it is a blast I hope it's
a big hit how does it work well it's so
it's like the word game that we play in
The New York Times every time
you said it but Legos was around before
uh that game and uh you know it's it's
basically just like that world doesn't
have you and it's also not televised
well this show lingo is a blast I can't
wait for you guys to see it because it's
just as addictive your bucket list of
things you want to do yes one thing one
one thing one thing I would love to Star
on Broadway you know I'm a producer on
the show ain't no mo which is on
Broadway now and you guys please go see
ain't no mo on Broadway I'd love to be
on Broadway
starring on Broadway well you know
people yes
also 30th anniversary of supermodel yes
you better work yes we go to work you
know it uh RuPaul thank you it's always
great to have you the 15th season of
RuPaul's Drag Race premieres on Friday
January 6 on MTV and catch RuPaul
hosting what's the name of game show
lingo Bingo on January 11th right here
on CBS what's that other word game I
guess I wasn't supposed to say it lingo
and there's